البرلمان الفرنسي يناقش مشروع قانونا للحد
من نشر صور الاطفال على الانترنت القانون
تم اقراره سيكون الاول من نوعه في العالم
والهدف حمايه الخصوصيه الرقميه يستهدف
القانون ايضا المؤثرين الذين يكسبون المال
وبناء قاعده متابعينا عن حساب المشاركه
المفرطه والنشر المتكرر لمواقف ويوميات
اطفالهم عبر وسائل التواصل لكن طبقا
للاصوات المؤيده للقانون فان حتى في حال
نشر الصور ومقاطع الفيديو العفويه قد
ينتهي بها الامر في مواقع الانترنت
المظلمه وشبكات استقلال الاطفال جنسيا
[موسيقى]
من مصر والاردن سالنا الناس ما رايكم في
قانون يضبط نشر صور الاطفال على الانترنت
من قبل ابائهم
[موسيقى]
انا حر مثلا انا ده ابني بنزل له الصور
افرض مثلا ان هو بيلعب لعبه معينه او كده
او حاجه هتفيد غيره او هو مثلا شاب مجتهد
في شيء معين ايه المشكله اما انزله طبعا
من حق كل اب ان هو ينزل صور ابنه مدام
هتفيد غيره اللي عاوز ينشر يعني ينشر
اولاد الصور اولاده براحته ينشر واللي مش
عاوز مش عاوز لكن يعني بترجع للشخص نفسه
يعني لان الاطفال او الكبار او الصغيرين
ده حوريه شخصيه للاسف يعني في اباء
بيستغلوا اب
نائهم بطريقه مش لطيفه عشان الفيوز عشان
الريتش والحاجات دي فطبعا يا ريت يكون في
حاجه زي كده طبعا لحمايه الاطفال الا لازم
الاباء يكونوا حراسه جدا في الموضوع ده
لان دوت طبعا زي ما قلت لك بيسبب كارثه
كارثه كبيره جدا
الاباء هم اكثر ناس خايفه على مصلحه
الاطفال فاكيد مش هيعملوا حاجه تضرهم ابدا
وهم لو شايفين ان النشر ده في مصلحتهم
اكيد هيعملوا لو مش في مصلحتهم اكيد مش
هيعملوها
[موسيقى]
اليوم هذا جزء من حمايه عامه للطفل اذا
كان الاهل بشكل عام يجهله الاثر السلبي
احيانا لنشر مثل هيك صور فاليوم لازم يكون
في اطار قانوني شويه يرجع الناس لصوابها
مع هذا القانون الى حد ما يعني حتى يحمي
حقوق الطفل لانه كطفل صغير هو
ما بيحمي نفسه او ما بيستطيع انه يقرر هو
ايش بده فاهله هم عم بقرروا عنه او شو
الطريقه المناسبه لحياته فالاهل هم اللي
بقرروا فهذا طفل ممكن في المستقبل ما يحب
هذا الاشي او ما بده بالعكس هذا قانون
ممتاز يعني الا انه في ناس بتطلع مثلا على
تطبيقات تيك توك وهيك
فبعد مثلا اطفال تخويف الاطفال وهيك وفي
ظاهره كتير منتشره حاليا اللي هي انه
الاطفال بيمسكوهم بحطوهم وبيقعدوا عن طريق
انه تقريبا زي ما بدنا نحكي تسول عن طريق
الاطفال هم حاطينهم وبردوهم على السوشيال
ميديا قاعدين اللي بحط اطفاله وبشغل
القران وانه الاطفال وعشان الناس ياخذوا
يبعثوا لهم مصاري وحزنهم اطفالهم فهذا انا
برايي اشي خطا جدا كذا مره يعني نشرت على
الوسائل التواصل انه ممنوع الامعيات اللي
بتنزل صور ابنها وصور مش عارفه كثير غلط
هذا الموضوع يعني سيء انه حتى يعني ممكن
من العين ممكن انه ناس يستفزوك بصور
اولادك يعملوا تركيب صور ويصيروا لسرقات
للشغلات زي هيك
من عمان ينضم لنا الدكتور صخر الخصاونه
محامي هي مختص في تشريعات والاخلاقيات
اهلا بك دكتور معنا في الصباح العربيه
اقتراح قانون لضبط نشر صور الاطفال على
الانترنت ماجد وهذا القانون في حال فورد
وهل هو قادر بالفعل لحمايه الاطفال من
الاستغلال ايا كان
صباح الخير بدايه لحظات وكل المستمعين
يمكن هذا القانون او هذا المشروع القانون
من
افضل المشاريع القانونيه الحاليه حيث في
السنوات الخمسه الاخير نتيجه كتب
الاستخدام مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
واستخدام الاطفال في عمليات الدعايه او
العمليات جلب
الاصوات والتعليق والتعليق ظهرت ان اكثر
من قضيه دوليه في العالم الغربي بحيث انه
لجا كثير من الاطفال الى المحاكم من اجل
تقرير عن هذه الصور هي ملك لهم امرك
لابائهم هل يملك الاباء
صلاحيه نشر الصور
وبالتالي انه لا يكون الطفل حق الاعتراض
سجلت اكثر من قضيه في امريكا في كندا في
النمسا في المانيا حتى في فرنسا لكن هذه
القضايا لغايه الان لم تنتهي فبالتالي كان
لابد من التفكير بوجود
قانون هذا القانون يتفق مع المبادئ
الدوليه الاتفاق
في قانون
من قانون ح في قانون يعني عندما نتحدث
بلغه القانون في قانون حريات الشخصيه
حريتي بالشخصيه انه انا حره انزل صور
اطفالي من عدمه لماذا القانون يقيدني
لابد بدايه ناخذ بعين الاعتبار بانه هنالك
اتفاقيات دوليه واهم الاتفاقيه الدوليه
العهد
والقانون والاتفاقيه الخاصه هي المتعلقه
بالاطفال لم نكن نواجه مشكله عندما نتحدث
عن الاطفال والتصوير في وسائل الاعلام
دائما باستمرار او من شخص دائما نقول بان
تصوير الاطفال ممنوع تصوير الاطفال والطفل
مقصود فيه واقل من 18 سنه الا بموافقه
اولياء امورهم او والدتهم او متولي
الرقابه مثل مديره مدير المدرسه مدير
المدرسه وكنا نضع القيود المتعلقه بتصوير
الاطفال دكتور المشكله الان في ظل مواقع
التواصل صار من ينشر الصور الاولياء نفسهم
في هذه الحاله القانون المشروع القانون
الفرنسي يضع شروط محدده في حال اهانه
الطفل او ايذاء نفسيا يحاسب الاولياء صحيح
صحيح لكن الان احنا تحولت المشكله من
وسائل الاعلام الى الاهل ذاتهم فبالتالي
هذا التحول ادى الى انه من ناحيه
القانونيه لا يوجد ما يمنع الاباء من نشر
صورهم باعتبار
لكن المشكله تكمن بان الاطفال الاطفال
يتعرضوا من خلال هذا النشد الى قضيه مهمه
وهي قضيه التنمر الالكتروني فبالتالي
باستقلال الصور الاطفال من قبل زملائهم في
المدرسه وتبدا المشكله فبالتالي اول عرضه
خطر للاطفال من نشر الصور اللي قبل الاهل
هي قصه التنمر الالكتروني ومن ثم تليها
استغلال اصحاب النفوس السوداء في تركيب
واستغلال الجنسي للاطفال واستخدام الصور
المنشوره الان الفكره التي التي يذهب
اليها المشرع الفرنسي في هذه المسوده او
ما يذهب اليها هل يملك الطفل عندما يبلغ
سن الرشد 18 سنه فاكثر هل يملك الحق في ان
يعترض على هذه الصور
اهله مثلا اذا تم نشر صور طريفه له او
فيديوهات طريفه قد تحرجه في المستقبل
الاصل الاصل الان ان الاباء يملكون نشر
صور الاطفال
لكن الاصل القانوني الذي يجب ان يكون ان
يكون للطفل حق تقرير حق تقرير انه هل تبقى
هذه الصور بعد ان يبلغ سن الرشد ام لا
واذا كان له واذا رفض ان تبقى هذه الصور
فمن حقه ان يقاضي ان يقاضي حتى يزيل عنه
الضرر النفسي الذي قد تلحق به نتيجه هذه
الصور شكرا جزيلا وبالتالي اليوم اليوم
للاسف انتهى وقتنا تماما من عمان الدكتور
صخر اخصامنا محامي مختص في التشريعات
والاخلاقيات شكرا جزيلا دكتور اتواجدك
معنا